mike a very interesting game last night
i didn't think i was going to get sucked
into that game
but i i really loved it it was there was
so many interesting little facets to it
uh on both sides
but i mean i walk away from it thinking
you know when i looked this up last
night the giants now against the eagles
and the cowboys since opening day 2017
are oh
and 13.
and you know at some point you say
you know
the rivalries hardly exist anymore
you know you to be a rivalry
both sides have to be
competent competitive really pretty good
and you know the giants uh
although i must say they showed a lot of
fight
if the giants are 31 and the jets are 32
there is a chasm between 31 and 32
because at least the giants can compete
well no you're right they have a win
first of all which makes them
dramatically better than the jets and
they don't get blown off the field every
time they play they had a close game
against the cowboys a few weeks ago they
had a close game last night 21-10 lead
late in the game they just couldn't hold
that lead and
look that's the problem you got to be
able to close it out and for the eagles
it was kind of a microcosm of the way
they've been the past few years the
moment you give up on them the moment
you say they're done
that's when they somehow find a way to
scratch and claw their way back into it
we saw it last season we saw it the
season before we saw it last night with
the eagles finding a way to win that
game at a time when
i was just ready to say done over that's
it let's hear from carson wentz on
coming back from that 11 point deficit
with only five minutes left to play
what does a game like this do to your
team for the rest of the season
i mean to answer the latter part of that
question it does a lot for us it does a
lot for our confidence the way we've
really fought to come back in the last
couple ball games to actually do it and
pull out a win um it's huge for our
confidence and we know it's a divisional
game so it's huge for uh for the nfc
east as well um as far as the the other
question
i mean we'd love to not be in those
situations where our backs are against
the wall you know we we left a lot of
plays out there um we were in the red
zone a lot and didn't score many points
so those are things we've got to clean
up and be better
but when our backs are against the wall
and we've got to make plays i'm going to
give guys all the opportunity in the
world to make them
and look the eagles have been very
competitive in recent weeks they gave
the steelers a very good game a couple
of weeks ago they almost came back and
forced overtime against the ravens two
of the best teams in the league
so that's what made it more stunning
that they were behind last night but it
ultimately made it not that stunning
peter that they found a way to get it
done because they have found a way to
hang around they have found a way to
come back when you think it's over and
if you're going to do it against any
team you may as well do it against a bad
team then you're more likely to pull it
off against a bad team and that's what
the eagles were able to do last night
think what we found out last night is
that
you know
the philadelphia defense is going to
keep
the philadelphia offense in the game
you know and
last night especially you know you you
really look at
the stalwart players on that defense
along with the absolute weakness of the
giants at tackle oh my gosh andrew
thomas
what are they going gonna do with andrew
thomas how can you
hide him week after week i i you know
that's that's a real tough one for the
giants right now and when you're the
fourth pick in the draft shouldn't you
be
a little stronger and a little quicker
laterally i mean just maybe
he just he was awful last night and he's
been awful through the first half of
this season but brandon graham fletcher
cox last night some signs of life from
vinnie curry
those are the kinds of veteran players
and brandon graham making the exact same
kind of play he made on daniel jones
that he made on tom brady to basically
sew up the super bowl
uh you know in 2017.
that's right that's right and you can
count on brandon graham in those moments
and that was the key and the thing about
daniel jones and look before we get to
the moment that daniel jones will never
[Laughter]
there is no clock in his head it's not
that it
isn't working it's just not there when
when you're trying to drive down the
field for a potential game-winning field
goal you have to have some awareness
there was no awareness and it's not like
he took a deep drop and was waiting and
and the clock finally ran it just he
took a shallow drop and what does he
expect what do you expect when you're
just barely back behind the center and
you're just taking your good old time to
get rid of the football
and some guy comes crashing down on you
the ball comes out there's nothing about
his demeanor in that moment peter that
suggested he even factored in the
possibility that someone might hit him
yeah and with a line as leaky as civ
like as that offensive line he's got to
know he's got to have more of a clock in
his head and mike daniel jones now has
started 19 games in the nfl
he has either thrown an interception or
fumbled now not lost to fumble
necessarily he's thrown an interception
or fumbled in all 19 starts
now that's not indictable in and of
itself
but
in general in general
he has not yet learned the lesson
of uh ball protection as much as he has
to learn it
and i just look at this right now and
say look it's not like the giants are
going to go out and strengthen
themselves on the offensive line they're
not
but i do think that they're going to be
listening
you know i think if you call dave
gettleman and want to talk about evan
angry at evan engram they would listen
you know he's been a re he's been a
disappointing player overall for them
but i think the giants could be active
in the trade deadline the other way but
as of as for daniel jones i saw a lot of
things that i liked last night
but the one thing i saw that i don't
like is his continued carelessness in
the pocket
yeah and you know you hear all the time
we're going to work on that we're going
to make it better we're going to find a
way to fix it we're going to do this
we're going to do that i mean
sometimes it's just who a guy is and
nothing you do is going to change the
fact that when he's out there in the
fray
there's something missing and there was
something missing all right last night
when daniel jones was trying to throw
the ball with the game on the line he
just got crushed
and again it was almost like he was
surprised oh yes they sent people
after me to try to keep me from doing
what it is that i want to do like he
he's not a pitcher you know pitchers
don't have to worry about somebody
coming out of nowhere and knocking him
down it's kind of like that like yeah
daniel you may get hit you may be
in a position where the ball gets
knocked out of your hands you need to be
aware of that you need to be ready for
that and nothing they've done so far has
changed that
back to the eagles
let's hear a little bit from doug
peterson
because
he
he continues to have moments where
people are like what what is he doing is
this a guy who won the super bowl uh at
least carson wentz doesn't have that
where people can say is this a guy who
won a super bowl because he technically
didn't here's peterson talking about
wences performance last night
man i thought he hung in there i thought
he battled um
face of adversity down a couple scores
there in the in the fourth quarter and
and really hung in there and you know it
wasn't um
you know maybe on the stat sheet things
look good but but there's some there's
some throws and there's some decisions i
think he would want back but i tell you
what he's
he's he's the leader of our team for a
reason and you saw that tonight
uh leading our team down there to uh to
get that uh you know uh the two two
scores late in the game but um overall
hung in there played tough again tonight
a decision that maybe doug peterson
would like to have back fourth and three
early in the fourth quarter down by
four points hakeem butler
his first snap in the nfl never caught a
pass he's the guy they go to that's the
guy that peterson has a play drawn up
for i mean if you're looking for the
element of surprise i guess you've found
it but
you better be sure you're going to be
able to work it out and the
the guy who's a converted offensive
lineman become a tight end is going to
be in a position to make the catch peter
yeah you know that was one of the
strategic things last night that i
didn't like not that i think they were
down 14 10 at the time and kicking a
field goal would made it would have made
it a one-point game and so
i'm sure he's figuring
uh you know who knows how many more
times we're gonna get the ball blah blah
blah but the reason i would have kicked
the field goal is it was a a little bit
too far to be it wasn't fourth in a yard
and and b i i think you know at that
point
what did you really trust about what the
eagles could do on offense
i mean i i didn't trust anything that
they were doing now when they started
hustling
and they started playing basically hurry
up for the last six minutes in essence
uh
you know they were a lot more efficient
and they you know they chewed up yards
but
at that point in the game i didn't trust
them i would have taken the three right
there
yeah there's still plenty of time left
to be played in the game they could have
all they need is another field goal at
that point so uh but it doesn't work and
the next thing you know it's 21 to 10
and it just felt like it was over it
felt like it was done
and i have to give the eagles some
respect for finding a way out of that
hole usually you don't see that happen
the giants are the ones who blew that
lead though joe judge head coach of the
new york giants not happy with what
ultimately happened to his team here he
is
you know we can't all have one off you
know i can't make a bad call player
can't say my bad that adds up throughout
the course of the game so we just can't
do that right there we've got a coach
better we have to play better and we got
to finish the game out when you have we
have an opportunity we've played enough
ball at this point we know we have as a
team we should understand how we have to
play as a team we know we have to be a
team that's got to grind out wins we
could do things just a little bit
tougher and that's all right we're okay
with doing it that way we put ourselves
in position a lot of games now we've got
to control the things we can control and
that comes down to the penalties and the
turnovers we have to do a better job of
that as a team
to make sure that we give ourselves the
opportunities to capitalize on the work
we're putting in
yeah oh he's absolutely right and it
sure felt like it was going to work out
last night it felt like it was going to
be a different vibe for this giants team
after starting off 0-5
to win on sunday against washington in a
hard-fought game that went back and
forth and they ultimately held off
washington at the end of the game if
they would have been able to pull off
that two wins between a sunday and a
thursday maybe you feel differently
about them maybe there's a way to
scratch and claw their way back into a
division title conversation especially
when you're in a division like the nfc
east but not to be for the giants and
and really what better encapsulates
their season i've resisted for as long
as i could
daniel jones
the 80-yard run the 80-yard
non-touchdown run
the
the the run where the guy breaks into
the clear shot out of a cannon you
rarely see it from a quarterback
and all he has is green grass in front
of him
and it's fall down go boom for daniel
jones it was funny but i also felt bad
for him you never see that happen
everybody worries about that right i
don't want to go out there and fall down
like kramer well daniel you fell down
like kramer
you know mike
the thing about that play after the game
i i stayed up and i listened to the uh
yeah this is great stephon diggs is
fantastic
that was hilarious and the homes give
them homes credit give them a holmes
credit i would never been able to run
that that far either but mike you know
what what you thought of
you know and again you don't want to
pick on daniel jones because hey you
know you've got pretty good athleticism
to outrun a defense
you know so so
good for him
but the thing that kind of bothers you
about oh my god that's hilarious who did
this mike mike who did i don't know it
wasn't me it wasn't me but that's pretty
much the night for the new york giants
there it was the winners in their grasp
and there goes the win probability
you know the thing the thing i was going
to say is that you know it's
and i don't mean to sound like i'm i'm
picking on the guy because he doesn't
have a great awareness in the pocket a
lot of times
but that also showed a little bit of a
lack of awareness i mean if he even
looked around slightly peripherally
there was nobody who had a chance to
catch him nobody
and it isn't like the crowd is so loud
that you can't hear anything and you
can't really sense what's around you
there's there's barely anybody there
so that that just i don't know that
as funny as it is and all that other
stuff and you don't want to make too
much of it but man you got to have a
better sense of where you are if you're
daniel jones
well and it probably was the first time
in his life definitely the first time in
his nfl career that he was in a spot
like that where you're breaking free and
you're actually going to run that far to
the end zone and there really is no one
behind me this makes no sense i should
just fall down but how many times have
we seen a guy who breaks into the clear
like that peter who looks up at the
video screen we didn't see any of that
guys rely on that video screen and
they're still running them in the empty
stadiums they surely had them on last
night in a sparsely filled lincoln
financial field you look up you see that
there's no one behind you you
confidently run into the end zone there
wasn't any of that for daniel jones it
was just it was just hold the pieces
together in the hopes that the car
doesn't fall apart before it gets to the
finish line and unfortunately for daniel
jones the car fell apart before it got
to the finish line it ultimately wasn't
consequential they still scored a
touchdown on that drive
but
but still it was a moment it was a
moment at a time when the game was just
boring that was the moment the game went
from boring
to not boring
just in that one moment right because it
was just you know and last night was a
strange night it was the only night that
there was a presidential debate up
against a football game
and
frankly
eagles giants presidential debate
curious about you know
the fate of our nation the future of our
world i was paying a little more
attention to that than the football game
at times but once that happened it's
like well oh okay now we got a football
game here debate kind of boring frankly
which is good boring is good in
comparison to the first one but that was
the moment where it kind of grabbed your
attention and held your attention on the
football game so i guess thank you
daniel jones for giving us something to
pay attention to and also something to
talk about today
i couldn't really watch the debate i
tried a couple of times i flipped it
over during commercials but
i don't know there's something
that is so
uh
reprehensible about our political
process right now i just couldn't get
into it kind of glad i didn't i'm kind
of glad the especially the second half
of this game really made it very
watchable
yeah and uh look the reality is 50
million people have already voted so
last night's debate uh in many respects
irrelevant how many minds are you
changing right now
i mean highly absolutely
absolutely how in the world how in the
world can you be undecided i i mean come
on tell me the truth how did unless you
just woke up from four years in asleep
you know how are you definitely not
definitely not changing the minds of the
people who've already cast their ballots
that's for damn sure it's too late for
the 50 million who have already pulled a
leave or punched a button or whatever it
is that you do oh you fill in the little
i already already voted how do i forget
i already voted you fill in the little
square you just isn't it amazing mike by
the way that to me i find it amazing
that i think there were 123 million
ballots cast
in the in the presidential election four
years ago something like that
so 123 million now there's been what
already 53 million
i mean there's still a week and a half
to go before the election
i i mean how many people are actually
going to vote before the election i mean
i am how many are going to vote on
election day how many are going to be
left to vote on election day that's the
key i know they may have everyone may
have voted by then
so uh still many ballots to be cast in
the nfc east congratulations to the
philadelphia eagles with that win at two
four and one
two four and one is actually better than
two and four they're in first place over
the dallas cowboys when you're under 500
a tie boosts your winning percentage and
winning percentage may be relevant this
year let's hope it isn't we'll be
talking about that dynamic coming up
later in the hour but for now the
philadelphia eagles are your first place
team and that tie
that they had with the bengals earlier
this year that is going to avoid a lot
of headache and a lot of heartache and a
lot of mathematical
uh effort that we otherwise would need
unless one of the other teams is
involved in a tie
because i think that thai's either going
to just give it to them or they're just
going to miss out on it but we're not
going to have to worry about any tie
breakers this year in the nfc east peter
yeah i don't think so either mike and
i think the eagles are clearly the best
team in the division
um i don't see how i mean i think dallas
is going to go to washington this week
and lose the the thing that the cowboys
are most vulnerable
the the place where they're most
vulnerable you know on the offensive
line that's where
washington is going to have a great
great advantage um on their defensive
front against washington's offense or
against dallas offensive line but i i
also think in general that
when you look at this division this year
it's going to be it's going to spur a
conversation
and it should spur a conversation
that
if you make the playoffs by winning your
division that it should not guarantee
you a home playoff game and that is a
rabbit hole that can we could go down
for about an hour
but i simply cannot believe
that
you know the nfl this year and and you
know really i hope it isn't like i'm
rooting against the eagles or for them
to lose every week i hope that a team at
six nine and one wins the division or
five ten and one wins a division and
gets a home game and then i hope the
fifth seed in the nfc playoffs is like
12 and four
because it'll just point to the
absurdity
of giving a team a home game in the
playoffs for winning the worst division
in recent history but peter there's
nothing wrong with hoping for that
because the nfl will only deal with a
situation when it does create a
ridiculous outcome like that even though
the league knows that it can it won't do
anything about it until it actually
does that's why i keep hoping that in a
super bowl someone fumbles at the two
yard line and the ball goes forward and
goes out of the end zone and the casual
fan is like wait why does the other team
have the ball on the 20 now that's the
only way they're ever going to address
that rule that i despise it has to
happen in a big spot it has to happen in
a spectacular way it has to be six nine
and one hosting twelve and four before
the league says we need to do something
about it and and look peter i don't
wanna go down the rabbit hole either in
part because sims and i have been
talking about it throughout the week and
people probably get sick of hearing it
but i would like to go back to three
divisions per conference the way it was
prior to 2002 because i think if you go
three divisions per conference you
really do have meaning in winning a
division you can say all right you're
the best of five or six teams you get to
host a playoff game the other people are
wild cards most of them are going to
have to go on the road that's kind of
the way it works out with four teams per
division you're always going to have
this possibility if not reality that you
get four crappy teams that happen to be
in the same division and it seems like
we see something like this far more
often than we don't
there's two reasons why that'll never
happen it might happen in 50 years it's
not going to happen in the next in the
foreseeable future number one the nfl
doesn't want four more franchises and i
assume you would want every team to have
the same number every division to have
the same number of teams why so how many
years yeah how many years peter peter
how many years was it four five and four
per conference why not five six okay so
if you're comfortable if you're
comfortable having a different number of
teams in the division that's that's
another another issue but i'm telling
you the reason why they won't do this
anyway
is because
uh owners and gm's and club presidents
like the fact
that you only have to beat three teams
to win a division you know they they
like that they like that hey we've won
the nfc east or whatever division there
is they love that
and and it really doesn't matter
if it doesn't create the most just
outcome
you know in the course of a season it
just matters because then you can put on
your resume we won this division x
number of times
you're absolutely right though
you're not going to find a single owner
who is going to give up the possibility
of a one in four chance to win a
division so there's eight divisions
instead of six nobody says boy a
division title is meaningless in the nfl
because there's eight divisions instead
of six i mean under that math let's have
16 divisions two team divisions hey
division champion but but that's the
thing you're not going to have teams
willingly give up an easy path to a
division championship because and jerry
jones said it this week it's like manna
from heaven that the cowboys are in this
bad division where they can pull the
inside straight and win the division
even though i don't think they will it's
a lot easier for them there than it
would be if they were in the nfc west or
the afc north this year but i i think
you've hit the nail on the head it's
going to take something like 4 and 12
hosting 13 and 3 to create the up cry
necessary or outcry as the case may be
to get this changed even then you're
going to have to get at least 24 owners
to say
nah we don't like having a one in four
chance each and every year of winning a
division and hosting a playoff game and
i don't think that's ever going to
happen anytime soon or uh like you said
in 50 years
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports